[Music]
my secret is my secret is my secret is
so my secret is a few years ago my mom
passed away from a disease called ALS
and for some reason I just felt a huge
sense of relief even though like I loved
her so much taking care of her was a big
burden on my life and after she passed
away I just felt a sense of relief and I
felt a lot of regret about that my
secret is that I'm Ukrainian and my
whole entire family there is from the
Mafia my secret is that when I was 2
years old my mother grew weed and made
$46,000 from it
all my friends think I'm a very happy
bright person but I'm actually really
sad a lot of the time and I don't know
if I should tell them that I struggle
with that so my secret is I am a
closeted gay and last night I got a
little too drunk at the bar and I made
out with this Jamaican girl from
literally four hours straight and I
always living my secret is I'm terrible
at getting tattoos I'm the biggest baby
even though I'm covered and work in the
industry my secret is when I was 17 I
checked myself into a mental health
hospital for a week
[Music]
my secret is my first kiss in the past
three years was with the dolphin my
secret is that one time when my sister
didn't let me use her perfume I spit in
it so every time she wore that perfume
she was wearing my spit my secret is
that I lost my virginity and a back seat
of my mother's van to a Russian girl who
didn't speak any English and my friend
was sitting in the front passenger seat
but he was sleeping the whole time and
to this very day he probably don't know
that he was a part of a very historic
event peace
my secret is I can make a dolphin noise
my secret is that I slept with my
sister's friend my secret is both my
parents are dating 26 year olds
I'm 25 my secret is I lied and told my
dad that someone hid his car with a
shopping cart when in reality I backed
into a parking marker you never found
out my secret is I'm your [ __ ] paper
wrapper yard I mean it's not really
secret I mean she might it might be a
secret for you but you ask her she'll
let you know I'm fine egg you'll never
catch me black and when I step on the
scene that's me get cracking are not
suction I love about that actually not
have not said girls I just makes happy
suburbs quick on do out of yep and
colors girls in the day when I mop up
the chopper stands out at 19 but I've
been DOS second in a bin house snatching
really with its out sagging I'm not
totally packing rocking with the mother
I met ago got all of the traffic I'll
let you have it huh my secret is I steal
food from the kids I babysit my secret
is that I've done too much cocaine and I
have to get a nose job probably about
half the time I get drunk I end up
pissing the bed in my sleep
my secret is that I wish I had a third
nipple oh okay
my secret is my freshman roommates were
witches and they have like little
prairie circles and they invited me
multiple times but I was too afraid to
do anything but yeah they they were
something else here's my secret when I
was a kid after an argument with one of
my friends I spat in his french fries
when he went to the bathroom freshman
year of high school I [ __ ] my pants at
school my secret is that I stole hella
groceries for my work my secret is I run
a tattoo shop out of my bedroom
my figure is that I just stole for the
first time from Sephora I slept with the
best friend of my ex-girlfriends my
secret is when I was in Africa my best
friend slept with a guy I liked and they
were both seeing people for Christmas
one year I got a hamster and his name
was hammy and he got a hernia so we had
to put him down at the veterinarians and
I can still cry to this day on an
instant about my dead hamster
my secret is I cheated on two exams act
in college my secret is that I actually
have an autoimmune disease and I grew up
mostly in and out of the hospital and
not everybody knows that about me
because I look pretty normal
my secret that most people don't know
about me is I have pretty bad social
anxiety or I get really nervous around
people but I'm pretty good at hiding it
and not many people know that about me
[Music]
I smashed my mom's friends and she was
28 years old and she was engaged so I'm
generally a really happy outgoing person
but sometimes I lay awake at night with
a lot of anxiety and I can't sleep my
mind just keeps racing and and I'm not
that happy person all the time
my secret is I dropped out of Community
College my second semester ultimately my
parents thought I had transferred
schools but the last two or three weeks
of my second semester I didn't didn't
show up
yeah they don't know yet they might no
no I don't know everyone quick
announcement have new idea for an
episode and it won't you guys so if
you're interested to people on Instagram
and wait for pose that will explain
everything that's pretty much it thank
you guys for watching and I'll see you
this Thursday
[Music]